wundabar z the woman who helped her
husband kidnap Elizabeth Smart in 2002
is set to be released from prison today
news crews have been watching the prison
where she's currently housed in Utah
around the clock bar Z has been in
custody for more than 15 years
smart told us this week she hopes bars
ease family will commit her to a mental
institution you said this woman does
need to be committed will you do
anything to make sure that happens
you know some members of her family have
said we don't want her here either I I
did make that call and I honestly I do
think that it probably would be the best
place for her under the circumstances
would be to be civilly committed it is
you know out to the family and so I just
would ask them again to really consider
civil commitment as much as for everyone
else's safety as as her own probably
John Blackstone is outside the prison in
Draper Utah John good morning good
morning well Wanda bars he has been
eligible for parole eligible to leave
this prison since 12:01 this morning but
so far there's no clear indication from
officials here exactly when she will
walk out of these gates now when she
does she'll enter a world where at least
one relative says she has no place to go
after more than 15 years behind bars 72
year-old Wanda bars II will soon be a
free woman
officials in Utah say they have no legal
right to keep her incarcerated after
discovering they made a mistake
in calculating her sentence miss bar Z
has served her time and we have to
release her in 2002 bars II helped her
husband Brian David Mitchell kidnap
fourteen-year-old Elizabeth Smart from
her Salt Lake City home smart told Gayle
King bars II stood by as Mitchell
frequently sexually assaulted her during
her nine months in captivity yeah she
would encourage him to rape me she would
sit right next to me like the side of
her body would be touching me
the release comes six years earlier than
smart expected because state officials
discovered they miscalculated bar Z's
sentence her attorney argues that once
bars he finished serving her federal
sentence she didn't need to serve any
additional time in state prison we
reviewed that with our legal counsel and
determined that we did have to give
credit for that time spent in federal
custody bar Z will now be under federal
supervision for five years she's got
nowhere to go her sister who did not
want to give her name says bar Z is
unfit to leave prison she's mentally ill
terribly mentally ill and she's very
manipulative bar Z was denied parole in
July for the second time at the time she
refused to be evaluated by a prison
psychologist we can't extend a person's
sentence regardless of need for
treatment or other factors when a person
has served their maximum time it's
unclear where bar Z will end up a
federal agent assigned to her case will
keep track of where she's living
meanwhile her husband Brian David
Mitchell remains in prison serving a
life sentence for the abduction of
Elizabeth Smart Norah I'll be watching
John thank you